if if mr if mr powell believes in his
arguments and that hey this is just
these this is the best we can do okay
then trade places trade places for six
months
go work in a production plan go live on
pennies an hour
and i want to see if you're going to
still make the same arguments when you
get back from that experience
jim keaney gets all emotional and does
grandstanding challenge says he
misconstrues the nature of the argument
that i've made what he doesn't seem to
get is that i fundamentally agree with
him that the goal is to improve the
lives of the workers so it's not a
matter of gaining empathy for them or
understanding their condition better i
understand their conditions stink
and i understand that we want them to
get better the question is what actually
delivers on making their lives better
i've argued in my published works and in
short in this video about why mandating
higher wages makes their lives worse why
mandating better working conditions
actually makes their lives worse jim
does nothing to actually engage the
intellectual argument and explain why
those policies would not have the
effects that i do
welcome to episode 136 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
in this opposing views style episode
where i talk about a contentious subject
and have an expert on from each side to
discuss
benjamin powell and jim keady joined me
to discuss the ethical implications of
sweatshops in developing countries
we discussed wages hours and work
conditions at sweatshops
we looked at things like the impact of
stable socio-political systems on
underdeveloped economies potential
solutions to poverty and more my first
guest benjamin powell is an economics
professor at the rawls college of
business in texas and the executive
director of the free market institute
powell is the author of out of poverty
sweatshops in the global economy which
is a comprehensive defense of third
world sweatshops
jim keady my second guest has been a
human rights advocate and anti-sweatshop
activist since the 90s but is mostly
known for exposing nike's work
conditions and treatment of workers
overseas he gives talks all over the
country about the moral implications of
sweatshops be sure to hit subscribe if
you enjoyed this episode if you want to
hear more opposing views this episode
was brought to you by nordvpn you guys
have heard me talk about why i love
nordvpn we're on tour right now well
technically i'm recording this after a
brief stop in nashville but dad and i
are on tour and well technically it's
his tour i'm doing the opening but
anyway nordvpn is a lifesaver it's not
as hard as being in canada where i use
nordvpn to get anything half decent on
netflix but it helps when you visit
random hotels that have things on
youtube randomly blocked
but not with nordvpn nordvpn is the
fastest in the world it keeps your data
safe and anonymous and did i say it's
insanely fast it doesn't slow down when
streaming like other vpns i've used i
can't recommend them enough they have a
new exclusive offer for my listeners too
this is a good one grab your exclusive
nordvpn deal by going to nordvpn.com
tmpp or use the code tmpp like the
mckayla peterson podcast but as an
acronym to get up to 70 off your nordvpn
plan plus one additional month for free
it's also risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee
benjamin powell welcome to my podcast
hey good to be with you
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
sure i'm the executive director of the
free market institute at texas tech
university and a professor of economics
here in the college of business
and
i've done a lot of economic research on
economic development migration political
economy more generally and i guess
that's why you invited me here to talk
today
yes this should be a good conversation
so i think
we should start off with
what is a sweatshop
so
a sweatshop is a factory in a usually in
a third world country or poorer country
uh often engaged in apparel manufacturer
although it can vary of what they
produce it you know there's no bright
line between just
manufacturing jobs in poorer countries
and something that's a sweatshop in the
pejorative sense but usually they have a
bundle of characteristics that could
include
very low wages by standards that we're
used to in the more developed world uh
poor working conditions which could be
safety issues or long-term health
consequences on the job long hours
generally unpleasant working conditions
uh often or sometimes using child labor
this kind of whole basket of
characteristics and there's no objective
criteria of exactly how low the wages
have to be or how bad the working
conditions have to be that labels want
to sweat shop or not but activists who
are anti-sweatshop activists look for
places that have this kind of general
set of characteristics
okay and then what are you what's your
view on
whether or not sweatshops are a good
thing or a bad thing
well they're a thing listen they're part
of the process of economic development i
know of no country that is rich today
that didn't go through something like
having a stage of development where
there were sweatshop jobs or at least
jobs similar in characteristics of being
low pay and dangerous working conditions
to what we see in sweatshops in the
third world i'm i'm talking to you from
texas but i'm a native of massachusetts
i grew up in a city called haverhill
massachusetts it was known as the shoe
city for its uh 19th century shoe
production my undergraduate was at
university of massachusetts lowell
lowell the heart of the industrial
revolution in the united states
the jobs that were in these factories in
the 19th century would be considered
sweatshops by today's standards in terms
of their pay their working conditions
so they're a stage of development that
countries go through while you're
building the proximate causes of higher
standard of living accumulating physical
capital technology building human
capital things that raise the
productivity of workers that eventually
cure the sweatshops themselves in the
process of competition with each other
as labor becomes more productive so i
don't say that they're a good thing or a
bad thing i say that they're part of the
process of economic development
and we should aspire to think about ways
that sweatshop workers lives can be
improved but doing so requires
understanding economics because if we
don't understand economics you're as
likely to harm them as to help them um
in particular i think a lot of what the
anti-sweatshop
activists have done over the last 20
years have been to advocate for policies
that
would actually make workers worse off
okay well we'll we'll get into that
is it still similar if americans say you
said you were from massachusetts and
they produced shoes but they were
producing shoes for americans right and
a lot of these sweatshops are producing
products
also for americans but they're not in
america so is that still a fair
comparison
yeah absolutely i think who they're
producing afar is really
not so material to us i think what's
different in today's sweatshops than in
those ones in massachusetts
is that they're
in a world where there's other countries
who are much richer and more productive
so if we think kind of like the process
of development in great britain than
united states compared to countries
today
from that like pre-industrial stage
in great britain so call it 1770-ish
to something that looks like
post-sweatshop that's like almost 150
year transition period for the united
states we're talking maybe
1830 to 1930 give or take a little bit
about a hundred year transition well why
did it go faster in the united states
part of it just maybe some differences
in our institutions and we can talk
about those later but another part is
where did they get some of the capital
it was british investors where did they
get some of the technology they stole it
from great britain so
that long process there if we think
about the sweatshop country circa
1960 1965 it's hong kong taiwan south
korea countries that were pre-industrial
at the end of world war ii but in about
a 30-year span go from pre-industrial to
post-sweatshop why does it go so much
quicker because there's international
capital and technology to flow in as the
world had become richer and we see that
same process playing out in places like
vietnam today
okay
interesting okay
so
anti-sweatshop people
are focused on the negatives of
sweatshops and you're saying that
they're not all the same across the
board that there's gonna be different so
what are the differences between
sweatshops and what are we seeing from
the anti-sweatshop people mostly and
what percentage of sweatshops look like
that well let's be clear actually for
the most part i agree with activists
about how bad working conditions are and
what the wages are in these places so
some people so my book that you probably
saw that got me to interview here is
called out of poverty sweatshops in the
global economy and some people have
characterized it as a defensive
sweatshops but it's
maybe in a pecu in a particular sense
but it's not a defense that says oh the
conditions aren't that bad oh the wages
aren't that low it says basically the
wages are as bad the conditions are as
bad as what people say they are
but we have to realize that there's one
very important characteristic of these
and it's that people choose to work
there
now admittedly it's from a bad set of
options otherwise they wouldn't be
choosing it you or i aren't going to
leave our job to go work in a sweatshop
because we have better options but when
a worker chooses it they're
demonstrating that in their mind they
believe it's their least bad option
which means if we're going to advocate
for things to help them
we shouldn't be taking their least bad
option away instead we should be
thinking about how to expand options
that they have
and the way that people would classify
this as a defensive sweatshops is
pointing out that these are the least
bad options that a lot of other people's
solutions are false solutions
and that part of the solution is the
process of development itself
but it's not one that disputes what the
actual conditions are
there in sweatshops today or at any time
in the historical past and this process
of
development okay
is the argument that there should be a
minimum legal wage in some of these
countries
well that's an argument that's put forth
frequently so how do you feel about that
is that reasonable
no it's not so we we have to understand
wage formation right so the most an
employer is going to be willing to pay
any employee and this is whether
sweatshop or whether here at texas tech
or wherever is
upper bound of product is going to be
worker productivity and econ speak it
would be marginal revenue product the
punch line is how much that worker
contributes to the firm's revenue so
let's say your worker creates two
dollars a day worth of revenue the most
an employer would be willing to pay them
is two dollars a day at two dollars in
one cent a day they're losing more by
hiring that employee so they never hire
them or they dismiss them now they don't
want to pay them that the employer
greedy profit maximizer would rather pay
them zero and pocket the entire two
dollars in profit what prevents them
from doing that is the workers next best
alternative that's their lower bound so
what is the other option they have to
work it if we want to talk about
improving the lives of workers it's got
to be about moving these two bounds if
we're not doing that if we're just
legislating legislating doesn't make
them more productive if you legislate
above that upper bound some workers are
going to lose their least bad
alternative and be thrown into the worst
alternatives and that's what a minimum
wage does so i mean you could have a
minimum wage that affects nobody at you
know five cents an hour there's going to
be nobody who's unemployed by a minimum
wage but to set it at a legally binding
rate that would increase the wages of
some workers is necessarily going to
lead to unemploying others and you know
when people talk about the minimum wage
in the united states and canada you know
the politicians all tinker around with
it somewhere around roughly what
low-skilled minimum pay would be anyway
as a result there's not big unemployment
effects they're relatively modest
firms don't rehire as quick they replace
with a little bit of capital but in
terms of sweatshop work these things can
be quite serious and i'll tell you the
united states the first
minimum national minimum wage law passed
in the united states was in 1938 with
the fair labor standards act
and i believe i'm remembered correctly
it set the minimum wage at 25 cents an
hour uh at the time average productivity
upper bound in the united states was
about 62 and a half cents an hour so it
did create some unemployment in the
united states but here's the real twist
it applied to the united states and all
of its territories at the time average
productivity in puerto rico was about
three to four cents an hour put a 25
minimum wage in the three to four
productivity mass unemployment business
closure so they had to amend the law so
that it didn't apply to a territory but
that's what it would be like taking a
developed country type minimum wage and
putting it in a sweatshop country today
so instead a lot of them talk about a
living wage which is really just another
name for a minimum wage it's just saying
we understand we can't take a united
states minimum wage and stuff it in
bangladesh instead it has to be based
off of cost of living there or something
like that
in practice these are still minimum
wages and if you set them high enough
you might for some workers be able to
get in between those upper and lower
bounds and some workers will get higher
pay and keep their jobs but others will
be laid off
and you know economists
and philosophers they'll talk about
these things and say but if we're just
going to use like a standard of the
well-being of workers maybe the wage
gains the people who keep the job are
worth throwing those other workers into
the worst alternative economics
doesn't tell you good or bad economics
tells you trade-offs
so the trade-off is some people get a
higher wage keep their job other people
lose their job but when we think about
this in the context of sweatshops and in
garment production
the numbers are really bad because if
you think about price sensitivities is
really what we're talking about here of
how responsive is the labor supply to
changes in prices and how responsive is
the demand for workers in response to it
most sweatshops are produced not by
multinationals or excuse me are not
owned by multinationals they have
domestic subcontractors who get orders
from international brands so the order
for those factory or the demand for
labor at those factories is as fast as
the next order
so if
the employer the multinationals are
profit maximizing which everybody
believes they're trying to do they're
already spreading their orders in such a
way that moving from bangladesh to
vietnam wouldn't make them any more
money on the margin on the next order
than from vietnam to for that matter the
united states or canada where some
clothes are still produced it's higher
wage higher productivity versus lower
wage lower productivity you're going to
equalize across these margins once you
legislate a higher wage in say
bangladesh
then the relative cost of that labor's
gone up you're going to start shifting
your orders so the demand for labor is
very very price sensitive now the supply
of labor if you're a worker in a third
world country you basically have to work
to feed clothes shelter your family
there's not a general social safety
generous social safety net and in my
view unfortunately we're not offering
near enough visas to move to the united
states and other developed countries as
a result the labor supply is not very
price sensitive economics would tell you
you stick these two things together and
what's going to happen is most of the
effect is going to be unemploying
workers of a minimum wage very little of
it will be extra wage for anybody who
stays employed and i just did all that
without talking about the ugly word of
elasticity which if any of your viewers
took economics classes they probably had
some teacher who sucked at teaching
principles of economics and when they
taught elasticity they calculated all
this stuff and the kids were like oh my
god this is boring elasticity it's about
price sensitivity and if you reverse
what i just said about the demanders
versus the suppliers in this market then
you get a very different conclusion but
that's not how this market works
okay what is elasticity
you describe that a little bit okay okay
right price sensitivity so whoever is
more price sensitive is going to be bear
more uh is going to be able to escape
uh so because firms can shift their
orders between countries quickly uh
they're not going to put up with simply
accepting a higher cost of labor they'll
readjust production to minimize their
overall cost meanwhile laborers aren't
very free to move to other countries or
to just sit out the labor market so they
just have to eat it so as a result
that's why you'd get most of the effect
in unemployment
rather than workers keeping their jobs
at higher wages because like listen nike
lane bryant pick whoever it is they
don't face a choice of make sneakers or
not make sneakers they have to choose
how to make sneakers and the substitute
for low-skill low-cost labor is fewer
workers and more capital or higher skill
higher productivity workers and when you
change the price of the low-skill
workers without changing that upper
bound their productivity then they're
just going to move to the substitutes
and that's what we see them do
that's very interesting i never
considered the fact that sweatshops are
actually competing internationally
so it's not just a problem within
countries it's actually across the world
yeah they're competing with each other
for orders from the multinationals from
around the globe what they're not
competing on so much as workers because
the workers aren't free to move between
what they're competing in country for
workers but not between country for
workers so when i say by the way this is
important for people to hear too about
that upper bound being low productivity
a lot of the reasons their productivity
is low has nothing to do with i'm not
saying anything disparaging about the
workers themselves i'm not talking about
their work ethic their human capital or
anything like that a lot of the reasons
for a low productivity have nothing to
do with the worker themselves and
everything to do with the place that
they're located in so
countries that have
low economic freedom bad property bad
enforcement of private property rights
not a very good reliable court system
the rule of law all of these things
limit the upper bound of productivity of
a worker because it's just hard to
organize economic activity as a result
someone can't create a lot of value for
a firm so if you take you know haiti is
a place where sweatshops have been
located uh imagine trying to do business
in haiti
imagine whatever you earn where you're
sitting right now if we plucked you up
and dropped you in haiti would you be
able to create as much value no the
whole environment around you can
strangers so a haitian when they're
allowed to migrate to the united states
their income goes up on average by a
thousand percent
that's sticking them in a place with
better property rights better economic
freedom better rule of law and for that
matter more physical and human capital
to interact with
and the same would be true if more
workers could move between countries
but a lot of the limits that upper bound
is bad governance in their in their
origin or their country where they live
okay
interesting
so
let's move into then boycotting
sweatshops because you see in the media
a lot of the time that oh you know it's
nike used as an example nike is using
sweatshops boycott nike
maybe buy from american companies that
are hiring americans that are paying
them at a fair wage
what are your thoughts on that
if you like helping wealthy unionized
american workers cool just have a buy
made in the usa campaign but let's not
pretend this is for the good of
sweatshop workers
if we start from understanding they're
choosing to work in that sweatshop
because it's the least bad option and
you say
no i feel icky about buying products
made with their labor instead i would
like to buy products made with
only
labor that has uh high wages good
conditions the right to organize
you can do that but what it does is it
decreases the demand for the workers in
the poorer countries which means more of
them lose their jobs and go to worse
alternatives and for that matter the
price they can get that upper bound if
you decrease demand for their product
with nothing physical changing about how
quick they can stitch a shoe or what
have you their upper bound goes down too
because part of that bound depends on
how much value you create in the mind of
consumers if consumers value products
less because they're produced in those
conditions
you've pushed that up or bound down with
through no fault of the worker but
through your consumer choices boycotts
are a bad idea and i'd say that
generally
uh over the last 20 years anti-sweatshop
groups have been
moving away from boycotts in general not
completely but have moved more in that
direction and i think that's a good
thing
interesting okay i don't think i've
heard that argument before so by the way
there's another version of this too of
uh ethical so-called ethical branding so
like fair trade coffee you've probably
seen yeah
so there's some versions of this with
sweatshop and they'll say you know we
are going to have there's a group or at
least there was it was called shop with
a conscience consumer guide and on their
their website they said all of the
things that we sell are sourced from
factories that only use high paid labor
that has good working conditions the
right to unionize and they pitch this as
if it was good for sweatshop workers
well i mapped out the source factories
they're all in the united states and
canada with a handful in a few out of
american countries it was basically a
buy made in the usa campaign in disguise
they weren't literally lying they were
producing them in factories that said
the characteristics they said
but they were pitching it as if this was
like oh yeah it's a nice factory in
bangladesh no there were none of those
factories in bangladesh you were
decreasing the demand for those workers
wow so there's a difference between
doing good and
or feeling good about something versus
actually doing good or one of my friends
has put it about bono there's a
difference between helping poor people
and singing about helping poor people
that's good uh that's interesting okay
so you're basically
putting forth the idea that
buying from sweatshops
eventually helps push that country
into a better place right
yeah let me put it this way uh
for some countries where sweatshops are
located right now
uh the sweatshops might be the least bad
alternative but they're no panacea
that's gonna guarantee that they have a
higher level of development a few years
from now
for
some who have so i'd say
sweatshops bring some of the things that
are the proximate causes for economic
development they bring in more physical
capital they bring in technology they
bring in investment
these are proximate causes not
underlying underlying as those other
things i mentioned about a rule of law
strong property rights economic freedoms
for countries that lack those sweatshops
are like a crutch that's the least bad
option for workers for countries
who are poor but get those things right
sweatshops are a stage of development
that help get rid of sweatshops
themselves
and that process happens much more
quickly today than it did in the past
so when i mentioned the sweatshop
countries in the 1960s right think of
the hong kong singapore taiwan south
korea these are all people that post
world war ii adopted property rights
economic freedoms and they grew rapidly
uh some of the places where they are
today i wouldn't say have high levels of
these freedoms and property rights but
they're places that are improving them a
lot vietnam has made a lot of
improvements china is a mixed bag over
the last five ten years or so but taking
a long view from say certainly from 78
but from 90 through 2010
they improved those things a whole lot
so
it was part of the process of
development there
cool
do you think in the future so say i mean
the world is getting richer in general
you say when some of these third world
countries develop further and there are
fewer sweatshops or the price of goods
going to go up and some of these
american companies are just going to be
crushed because they can't afford to
produce products anymore no so yes and
no so they won't be crushed and in the
end so let's play this process out so
some people call this and i think it's
wrong they'll say it's like a global
race to the bottom these companies keep
leaving a country and go into a poorer
one and it seems like it's a freaking
scorched earth like
uh hong kong
does not have sweatshops anymore
but it's not like it was left in the
dust what happened how did the process
go as they accumulated more capital and
technology and the workers had more
skills other firms would bid for the
labor and the garment factory couldn't
afford to bid the workers away
so so things like toy production and
circuit board production these are
little steps up the manufacturing ladder
from base apparel and the workers are
getting bit into them so now the
sweatshop can't hire the workers so
where do they go they go to a place
where the alternative is subsistence
agriculture because they can bid workers
away from that by offering a better
alternative so you can think of this as
like
one of the first rungs on the ladder of
economic development and the country
gets the sweatshops and steps on that
ladder the run of the ladder and as they
start moving up all the sudden the
garment factory can't compete so they
got to go somewhere else
and this process plays out but the end
this is getting back to your question
now what's the end of this stage is
there after it goes through east asia is
there some landlocked sub-saharan
african country who's the last to get
sweatshops and then are they stuck with
it no that process is still going to
happen there where productivity that
upper bound is going to go up other
people are going to try to bid them to
other industries
but now
factories won't have the option of going
to a place where there's lower lower
price labor without these opportunities
the only alternative will be
to have higher cost lower product excuse
me high productivity higher cost labor
much like what we see garments
manufactured which are still made in the
united states and canada and places but
much like production is here where it's
higher wage better condition now what
will happen once there's not low-cost
labor doing this somewhere in the world
the relative price
compared to other goods and services of
clothing is going to be higher
but we're going to be living in a world
that's so much richer that this will be
the least of our problems
cool
okay i have some other questions that
that's very interesting i've got some
other questions some of these might be
silly but i'm going to ask you anyway
um
why is it that sweatshop workers don't
unionize
um
there's probably multiple answers to
this but i'd say really when it comes to
unionization this is a sideshow in this
um
or it's a sideshow in terms of the
welfare of the workers in this part of
the world it's not a sideshow in the
movement and i'll come back to that but
when we're talking about people on
living standards that are barely above
the extreme poverty threshold we're in
the two to four dollar a day type income
range and we're talking about upper and
lower bounds like a union when it's
doing its job what a union's supposed to
do is negotiate on behalf of the workers
for better conditions and higher pay
but it can't ever get it up above that
upper bound above the upper bound the
employer doesn't want to employ the
union so it's all about that negotiation
range but we're talking
upper bounds in that two to four dollar
range
just moving between these
doesn't get you out of poverty it
marginally improves your standard of
living possibly and when we look across
countries about 85 percent of the
variation in wages is explained by
differences in productivity that upper
bound rather than the negotiation range
so at best it would be a small portion
of
an already low income that they could be
improving but we also have to understand
that the main way
that unions raise the wages and working
conditions of its members
is by limiting the employer's ability to
hire more workers
but if we're talking about
right that they restrict the labor
supply in order to jack up the price of
the laborers in the firm now that's good
if you're in the union but if you're on
the outside looking in and would like to
work it's bad for you well these are
countries where these are workers who
are escaping extreme poverty by getting
their their least bad option in a
sweatshop
unions might help some of the workers
who are in the factory but they're going
to hurt they're even poorer countrymen
who would like to
move into that type of development
now the reason unions are active in this
though has nothing to do with the third
world workers so
uh the afl-cio
unite a garment workers union have been
active in the anti-sweatshop movement
for years there's very few members of
those unions in poor countries their
main members are here in united states
canada development developed countries
they'd have you believe that they
advocate for minimum wage and working
condition laws for the third world out
of you know
workers of the world unite solidarity
stuff
[ __ ] they understand the economics
of this the substitute for high
productivity high wage first world
garment workers is low productivity low
wage third world workers if they can
price their competition out of the
market that enhances the demand for
wealthy workers in the first world
a union's job
and i don't begrudge them this in a
sense a union's job is to improve the
wages and working conditions of its
members the members of these unions are
in wealthy countries pricing their
substitute out of the market is the
union's job but they're disingenuous
when they say that they're doing this to
somehow help third world workers that's
bs
okay
okay so you you spoke about nike as an
example and garment factories but what
about places like apple so i remember
hearing and this is when i was a
teenager so i don't know how much of
this was accurate but i remember hearing
oh apple uses sweatshops to produce
whatever glass something to do with
iphones and conditions there are so bad
that they put nets around the factories
to stop people from
dying
if they're trying to jump out of the
building
have you heard this yeah of course i've
heard this uh
i don't know enough about any individual
instance of a potential suicide or
something but thinking about this more
systematically like
they're not coercing the workers to work
there the workers can leave the job it's
not an enslaved laborer whose only way
out is to kill themselves
people have
you know i'm an economist not a
psychologist i don't want to dabble in
why people would commit suicide under
any conditions whether in wealthy
countries or in poorer countries
but
the idea that this is a widespread
problem for apple is mistaken um
in particular i mean for apple
they can replace the workers because
there's lots of workers who want those
jobs
um
in general production of the type of
things apple makes will
garner a little bit higher wages and
better conditions than what you'll find
in uh
the more apparel orientated oriented
factories
okay that makes sense now if you want to
turn to like a
another dramatic where it involved a lot
of
people dying
you know some people will say i
understand the wage part but it's the
safety issue and so not so much suicide
but factory you know the ran up plaza
that collapsed in bangladesh uh a
factory collapsed and it killed over a
thousand workers who were working wow
uh this was in
2013 i think
but there have been other factory fires
in bangladesh that have killed workers
it you know people say we just have to
enforce the higher standards
the problem is that
the safety standards are part of the
cost of labor
so just like mandating higher minimum
wages mandating higher safety standards
raises the cost of labor and has that
exact same type of shift
away from those workers and while it's
very unfortunate for the thousand
workers who died in that factory
uh there are about four million people
who work in the garment industry in
bangladesh
for all of them that job's a step up
from the alternative
and mandating the higher safety standard
because of the accident of a few
is going to employ disemploy many more
who are otherwise making their lives
better so
some people will say obviously it was
bad for those workers who died in that
collapse well yes obviously just like
it's obvious fruits bad for whoever dies
in a car accident but we don't
extrapolate from that therefore we
should
mandate such safety standards on cars
that fewer people have them
um you know
an ex-post outcome that's bad for
particular workers
doesn't mean it justifies passing some
law that affects everybody else ex ante
it was still a good bet going into the
factory that day
ex post every one of them would have
chosen not to and for that matter the
employer who ended up in jail would have
also chose not to but we live in a world
with uncertainty
is there anything that
people can do or that the government can
do to
make third world countries richer that
involves sweatshops or making any laws
that improves condition is there
anything conditions is there anything we
can do to speed up this process
um i think let me answer you two ways
i have one answer that can definitely be
done with the will of our governments in
the first world that would make a
difference but isn't quite the spirit of
what you're asking
so
the best thing first world countries
could do for third world workers is
issue more visas
so if a bangladesh worker's
alternative to working in the garment
factory
isn't just something worse in their
country but is migrating to the united
states and getting a job
in a kitchen as a cabbie on a
construction site whatever
often that next best alternative that
is now higher than their productivity in
the garment industry
they'll choose to migrate and is that
development of bangladesh
no but is it development of humanity who
come from bangladesh i'd say yes
and that it's really humanity that we
care about not a particular geographic
patch of earth no one runs around saying
you know antarctica doesn't have enough
gdp it's penguins who cares uh at least
in terms of output uh but in terms of
human flourishing migration is a form of
development for actual humans and if
this was a different podcast about
migration i'd say it doesn't make the
origin country poorer in the process but
that's probably more than we want to
bite off right now
in terms of actually helping for
development in these countries
buying the products having
multinationals invest there is part of
the process but in terms of improving
their institutions and things that are
the fundamental underlying causes of
development
trading free with freely with them
showing the examples about the best we
can do
i think anyway i think it's ultimately
constitutions and governance are
enforced by the hearts and minds of
citizens in those countries that's
really hard to
impose them from the outside at least in
any way that makes them them stick
if
my friend chris coyne has a book called
uh after war the political economy of
exporting liberal democracy that looks
at u.s government interventions around
the world uh over the last hundred years
and says after the u.s has gone five
years ten years twenty years later
how liberal democratic are these places
and the answer is you know germany and
japan post world war ii are the
exceptions for the most part it doesn't
stick
um
so i don't think that there is such a
constructivist type role
for outsiders
as much as there is a trading role for
us
of interact on voluntary terms by buying
their products trading freely with them
exchanging ideas and welcoming more of
them to our countries
is probably about the best we can do on
a on a large scale are there more micro
type things you can do like if you're
sitting at home and you're an activist
and want to do something
uh you know churches have missionary
work where they go open up schools
if you open up a school in a place that
has child labor well why do children
work it's not because their parents are
ignorant evil or stupid it's because
they desperately need the meager income
of the child in order to support the
family so instead raise money to do your
missionary work where you open up a
school and you pay kids to go to school
if you pay him to go to school you can
bid him away from the factory so like
that's a very micro type thing
someone could take on as an initiative
to do because i can imagine someone
sitting there saying well i don't think
i can impact
you know the united states or canada's
immigration policy but you could do
something like that
so the key now why is that different
because we're not mandating what must be
done instead we're offering another
alternative
you make people better by giving them
more alternatives you don't make them
better by taking away their existing
least bad alternatives
oh i like that
okay let's go back to um immigration for
a second
so
wouldn't issuing more visas
wouldn't that affect american workers
poorly if there's an influx of cheaper
workers available nah not really so this
is another big area of research for me i
do a lot on immigration
so economists have studied for you know
more than 30 years the wage impacts of
immigrants on the labor force
for most
laborers in a developed country the
low-skill immigrants from poorer
countries are not a substitute for them
they're a compliment it doesn't lower
their wages in fact it might enhance
their wages
for those who they might substitute
economists have vigorously debated this
and i i i'm not one of the ones who've
written these studies but they get all
amped up and this is very different than
the general public the general public's
like oh my god they'll you know they'll
steal our jobs if it's south park right
uh where they'll push down our wages the
economist virtually none of them believe
that on net jobs would disappear for the
natives the question the native born
rather the question is the wages and
it's only those so here's how the debate
is now for like people without a high
school diploma
when lots of low-skill migration comes
in to compete with them do their wages
go down as much as about negative eight
percent or is it still slightly positive
positive one percent and whatever that
is does it last for more than like two
years before it returns to normal
that's what the economists are debating
so they're saying it's a very small
effect on a small subsect
subset of the native-born population and
it doesn't last very long
regardless of whether these people are
pro or anti-immigration overall that's
the wage debate among economists it's
just
not a very big thing because even for
low-skilled laborers without a high
school diploma they're not perfect
substitutes there's one big skill that's
usually different and that's
english-speaking ability
so you know it's moving from the
shingling on the roof to being foremen
of the roof because now you're the one
talking to the customers while uh newer
migrant labor does the more
labor-intensive part
so it's about reshuffling that's why
it's the debate of how long does it last
it's kind of like how long does it take
to reshuffle
okay
okay so maybe just explain a little bit
why does it why does it not last for
very long
uh because ultimately the natives have
skills that are different than the
migrant they might not have been skills
that were relevant when the migrant
arrived so if you were
sorry you said roofing if you were the
shingler on a roofing crew
that was your skill there is a migrant
who's a perfect substitute for that
skill so it might disemploy you and
you have to now get re-employed well
what skill do you have different well
you speak english
so maybe you go to part of the roofing
industry where your english language
skills more important and your wage goes
back up that's a margin that you're not
the same as the immigrant um
you know we could think of the same
thing about restaurants you know moving
from the back of the kitchen dish
washing to the front of the restaurant
hosting or lots of low-skilled jobs of
things like
like
this hmm it's also okay but thinking of
more long-term dynamic
uh if you know there's lots of low-skill
immigrants who can come into the country
that's a stronger incentive for you in
the first place to not drop out of high
school and to get your high school
diploma
too uh more competition yeah
interesting
okay
are there any other main arguments that
you have or you know of put forth by
people who are anti-sweatshops
that you'd like to address
or did we cover everything oh
i don't know if i want to toss up my own
things and then knock them down
um i would say the most so when people
ask like what's the best critique of
your position uh i think that's
something important most people who
advocate for a strong position for
something should know what the best
argument against is and
i would say that the
best argument against
involves those price sensitivities of
could we mandate this in a way that
lowered the
the price sensitivity so the
unemployment effect wasn't as big and
the price effect was bigger
um that's not the way it so maybe a
global minimum wage uh adjusted for
productivity so it makes it hard to it's
harder to escape by going between
countries
you're still going to substitute capital
for it and do the mix
so it doesn't perfectly do it but it
would mitigate on the margins some of
some of the bad effect that i have that
i've described but it would still be
there
wouldn't a global minimum wage after a
number of years just go back to exactly
how it was beforehand
wouldn't everything just kind of
equalize well it depends how you do it
if you do a global minimum wage that's a
one-size-fits-all one around the world
you're going to massively unemploy the
third world and shift things to the
first world so that would be a
unmitigated disaster but if you tried to
do some productivity adjusted one
between countries that could limit the
some of the switching between countries
in response to it
it would at least be less price
sensitive than simply bangladesh or
vietnam putting put in place
interesting but it would still have i
would say it would still have a net bad
effect on worker welfare which just
wouldn't be as bad as doing it country
by country
okay wow thank you very much for coming
on uh if people want to find you where
should they go
well you can google benjamin powell
economist and you'll find all sorts of
people who like me hate me have done
videos like this but if you're
interested in sweatshops check out out
of poverty sweatshops in the process of
development if you're interested in
migration my latest one on that's called
wretched refuse the political economy of
immigration and institutions
and if you want the other side of me
who's the drinking sarcastic traveling
one uh my best seller from a couple
years ago it's called socialism sucks
two economists drink their way through
the unfree world and that's an anthony
bourdain style uh economics travel
history book
oh wow that sounds like fun
okay well thank you very much for coming
on that was interesting all right well
thank you for having me this episode was
sponsored by paleo valley we all need
collagen it's like the glue that holds
our body together so much so that tiny
lines and wrinkles pop up if we run low
on collagen paleo valley's bone broth
protein
this guy
is
in my opinion the best way to get the
collagen you need in your diet other
than just eating steak but i eat this i
can actually eat this guys do you know
how exciting it is to have something
packaged i can eat without an autoimmune
response the bones are simmered in
filtered water and nothing else no
chemicals it's pesticide free and made
with 100 grass-fed and finished bones
you can add it to smoothies
baked dishes coffee or just mix it with
hot water which is what i do with salt
for a collagen loaded afternoon snack
i can actually eat this it's like
drinking coffee to me although my palate
is so weird after only eating meat for
three and a half years that i don't
think it actually tastes like coffee but
it's reminiscent to me like coffee it's
foamy and delicious and super healthy i
put three of these scoops in hot water i
don't know if you need three three
tastes good that's what i do go to
paleovalley.com and use code mp for 15
off your first order that's paleo
valley.com code mp for 15 off
enjoy the rest of the episode
jim keady welcome to the podcast thank
you for having me i'm happy to be here
this should be a good conversation
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
sure um
the way i got involved in the sweatshop
issue that we're going to be talking
about today back in the late 90s i was
an assistant soccer coach at st john's
university in new york city
at the time we were the ncaa division
one defending national champions the
best college program in the country and
while i was coaching i was also doing a
graduate degree in theology and in my
first class moral person moral society
my professor was encouraging me to find
a paper topic that linked moral theology
in sports two things that he saw that i
had a passion for
i eventually landed by chance
on looking at the nike corporation and
their labor practices in light of what's
called catholic social teaching and what
i found was if you wanted to pick a
company that completely violated
everything that this body of teaching
stood for and everything that saint
john's university claimed to stand for
nike was the perfect case study
and at the same time i'm learning about
this over in theology
over in athletics we are negotiating a
three and a half million dollar
endorsement contract with nike and part
of that deal i would have to wear and
promote nike's products
i initially said
privately to my head coach and anyone
that would listen to the athletic
department that i did not want to be a
part of this deal i did not want to be a
walking advertisement that was
exploiting uh poor people in the
developing world and i did not think
that st john's university the largest
catholic university in the united states
at the time
should be a promoting a company that was
doing things to workers that grossly
violated our mission and what we claim
to stand for and what we told the world
that we were all about
eventually because of my activism on
this issue i was given an ultimatum by
my head coach you will wear nike and
drop this issue or resign
i held my ground i was forced to resign
i became and still am the first and only
athlete in the world to say no to nike
because of the sweatshop issue
and that made big news and i was
starting to get invited to speak on
college campuses and
churches and union halls about what had
happened
and in my initial lectures that i was
doing on the subject i would have you
know the market fundamentalists in the
audience saying you know what the hell
you're talking about those are great
jobs for those poor people what the hell
else would they be doing if nike wasn't
there you know you can't compare wages
there to wages here
i knew from my research that they were
wrong uh but the competitive athlete in
me wanted to prove them wrong
so in the summer of 2000 i moved to
indonesia and i went to go live in a
place called tangarang it's this massive
sprawling industrial suburb outside of
the capital of jakarta indonesia and i
lived in a workers slum to survive i
actually gave nike the benefit of the
doubt i found the highest paid workers
in the region nike was paying them back
then about 1.25 a day
and living on a nike sweatshop wage for
one month i lost 25 pounds and i slept
on a cement floor on a thin mat with
rats and cockroaches and and spent my
days because nike wouldn't allow me to
work in the factory i actually asked
them if i could do that and they came
you know what jumped through all kinds
of hoops on why that couldn't happen so
i tried to do the next best thing and
just live with workers live on their
wages try to understand what their
reality was like and
and just listen to what their concerns
were what their stories were and i
promised those workers that i would go
home after that month and i would tell
their stories and i thought i was going
to do that you know maybe six or seven
weeks of a speaking tour and the first
year i ended up on the road for seven
months i spoke at 80 schools
and i saw there was a real hunger for
this kind of grassroots popular
education around this issue and then i
formed a nonprofit an ngo called
educating for justice and i spent the
next 14 or 15 years of my life full-time
going back and forth to indonesia
meeting with workers listening to your
concerns advocating for changes at the
factory uh pressuring nike pressuring
large institutional shareholders
pressuring institutional stakeholders
like universities that have these giant
contracts with big-time athletes like
jordan or lebron or mia hamm at the time
was a big soccer player had a contract
with nike and trying to get better wages
and working conditions for nike's
workers
and as i said i did that full-time up
until
2014
when i was eventually arrested detained
for two days deported and banned from
indonesia
i'm surprised it took them as long as
they did to do that so i've continued to
advocate from
afar things have changed a little bit in
indonesia just in the last few years
actually have friends that have moved up
and have fairly high positions in the
indonesian government where i think i
could go back there now
but it really did kneecap the kind of
cross-border solidarity work that i had
been doing
for 14 years up to that point
so now i do that work you know part-time
i try to help workers as much as i can i
get contacted you know sometimes it's on
a daily basis other times it's on a
weekly basis different things that are
happening at the factory nike certainly
has not solved their sweatshop problem
they're still exploiting workers
they're paying poverty wages they don't
respect workers rights to collectively
bargain
and fight for better working conditions
we just had a case uh we won on it's
about two weeks ago
uh indonesian woman factory worker at a
nike plant exercising her legally
guaranteed rights with regard to the
trade union movement that she's a part
of and she was illegally fired and it
took us months of advocacy to get her
reinstated in the job
and these are the realities that workers
face not just in nike's factories in
indonesia and vietnam where i have
visited personally but in the dozens and
dozens of countries where nike operates
all over the world where they're
consistently seeking out
um in people who are desperate and in
need of jobs so that they can exploit
that and maximize the return on their
investment for their absentee owners who
are also known as shareholders
okay well that was well said
what's your response to people claiming
that
some of these people have no other
places to go
that they could have the job or they
could just not take the job and it's
better than nothing yeah it's a lazy
argument and it's one that really lacks
imagination
right so let's say for example uh you
you're starving
right
you literally started and one of the
guys who was just on as we were getting
the call set up uh he's got a loaf of
bread
now he'll give it to you right
but you need to be his slave
you gonna take the bread
yeah from starving okay
is it a just situation
no but is it is it the bread owner's
fault though
not necessarily but we could can we
imagine hey
we can probably do this differently
right we need to morally check the guy
who's got the loaf of bread
and say yeah it's it's actually not
right for you to enslave her because
she's so desperate that she needs bread
because she's starving
right so
this is one of my my major critiques
with you know libertarian market
fundamentalists like mr powell who is
going to be on the other side of this
argument it just seems to me that they
lack the imagination to think that we
could do this any differently
and there's also a wildly false premise
you know i i read through you know his i
mean i got it all marked up i spent the
last two days going through you know the
ethical and economic case against
sweatshop labor a critical assessment
where he's taking people like myself to
task
and
this premise that guys like him start
off with has to be absolutely challenged
right why is nike in in let me take a
step back
he'll make the argument that companies
like nike and all these other apparel
and footwear companies are helping to
develop countries like indonesia
okay
why did nike go to indonesia
did phil knight when he came up with his
plan while he was a student phil knight
who's the founder of and chair emeritus
of nike when he was a student doing his
graduate degrees mba in stanford
business school
and he's
lays out his plan
how he is going to go to southeast asia
and exploit cheap labor and pump the
cost savings back into marketing and
branding to build this behemoth
when he was making that presentation i
have a colleague of mine who was in the
class when he made that presentation
phil knight wasn't talking about
developing the indonesian economy
why did he go to indonesia was it to
develop their economy
definitely not no it's to exploit cheap
labor period full stop
to exploit lacks labor and environmental
laws
full stop
so this ridiculous idea that these
companies are going to these places to
help these uh these countries develop
and then doing all these these mental
gymnastics and you know writing a book
about it to defend it is ridiculous and
we as citizens have to challenge that
premise from the outset
nike this isn't you know nike's not the
missionary is a charity they're not
there to help they are there to exploit
and then what the market fundamentalists
like mr powell will do is
is build a aetherian behind the existing
reality
and what i believe we need to do is
challenge the existing reality right
from the fundamental premise
if we want to move people out of poverty
if we want to make sure that people have
work that has dignity that also will
provide them with food clothing housing
health care education for their kids
some modest savings like all the things
that you would want out of a job
is building sweatshops the best way to
do that
now people like mr powell would say well
it seems like it seems like it's the
best way because that's what the market
has done
well the market's not perfect
right there are a lot of of market flaws
uh and market failures that we could
find as we explore this case study of
sweatshops
and what again what i find with with
folks like this these libertarian market
fundamentalists all they want to do is
just defend the reality that exists and
it seems to me they one lack empathy for
the people who are actually suffering
and two have zero imagination
on how this could be different
right and we have
markers throughout history where we have
seen things be different in terms of
social change so a woman like yourself
you if you're a united states citizen
you have the right to vote
was that always the case
not at all no so how did we get there
right it wasn't like
guys like mr powell all of a sudden
sitting in those seats as the white
alpha males going
yeah i think it'd be good for women to
be able to vote now
no it took organizing agitating it took
women going on hunger strikes being
beaten
unfortunately dying going to jail
to raise the consciousness
of the body politic to shift what in
social change is called the overton
window to the point where guys like mr
powell go
i guess that's a new reality and then
they'll write a study on why that new
reality is okay now
right it's the same thing they do with
these these economic
arguments so what's the solution then
for for sweatshops and isn't it possible
that putting sweatshots some sweatshops
somewhere it's not the purpose isn't to
make people richer obviously bringing a
sweatshop there it's to produce cheap
products
but couldn't one of the side effects of
that be
eventually
bringing people out of poverty
sure and so here's if you think of
the united states in terms of one of the
arguments that gets gets made by guys
like mr powell is look this is part of
the the natural development of an
economy hey we went through an
industrial revolution they're going to
go through an industrial revolution look
where we're at now eventually they'll
get to us right okay
one
where we're at if every country got to
where we're at as the united states we
would need seven planets
to sustain the level of consumption
so right outside it's unsustainable okay
now if if we're saying okay well we've
got
these factories and they're currently
paying poor wages there are labor rights
violations we used to have that here in
the united states
well how do you fix it
well we got to do is go back to history
i mean there's probably a dozen books in
my library that i could pull out to show
you how they fixed it you had trade
unions
they were militant they militantly
organized they leveraged public pressure
and they eventually got the concessions
that they wanted
okay
so if we know how to fix that
why are we putting these folks in
indonesia as an example
through the misery that our sweatshop
workers went through here in the united
states
that's crazy to me i'm an athlete right
i i after i i finish this interview with
you i've gotta shoot up to my high
school alma mater i coach with the
soccer program there i coach all the
goalkeepers
when i was a goalkeeper at christian
brothers academy my school i gave up
some really bad goals at times
and i gave up bad goals through college
eventually i got to the professional
level and i got to have his as first a
teammate and then a coach one of the
best goalkeeper coaches in the world
right my buddy timmy and he broke me
down and built me back up
right now when i'm gonna go coach my
goalkeepers today
20 something years later
am i going to coach them
how i was coached in high school
that led to me like giving up bad goals
and it wasn't really good coaching
or am i going to start them at the new
level
with the knowledge that i gained
over the arc of me making those mistakes
and learning the new technique coaching
techniques that i got from my buddy when
i got to the pro level
now the argument that someone like mr
palmer thinks oh no no those young
goalkeepers now let them make the bad
goals let them suffer let them lose
games let them be humiliated
why to defend some theory like we know
how to fix it
right so let's fix it and here's a
here's another one so if you and i went
to indonesia right now
and we were to go out uh both within the
capital and the big industrial areas
but even going out into more of the
countryside what you're going to see
is um
fiber optic telephone lines or fiber
optic cable lines that are being laid
down all over the place right so people
can get access to the internet
all right and to have decent decent
wi-fi decent cell phone signals all that
stuff okay
well
i
was in indonesia my first trip to
indonesia was back in 1993. i remember
when
most homes did not have a telephone this
is a 93.
you would go to what was called um
the wartell warong telephone
the telephone shop where you would have
to go into a little booth and there's a
little ticker and you'd say you know you
pick up you make your call and the
numbers are running at the end you're
going to pay whatever that amount is at
the end for how long you're on the phone
for depending on where your calls okay
so
if we're going to follow this
progression right if indonesia has to go
through the same development that we
went through
shouldn't every house get a landline
first
before we get to high-speed internet and
cell phones shouldn't every house get a
a dial i don't even know if you remember
they may not have been around but like
where you had to stick your finger in
mm-hmm
i had those then we went to push button
then you went to cell phones that were
the size of mexico that only the rich
had then you went to cell phones that
everybody got that we're about that big
and you were only making calls then we
went to phones that could do text
messages and calls then we eventually
evolved to where you know you're
basically on the starship enterprise
where i can lift my phone up and do face
time with like what we're doing right
now right yeah okay
well should indonesians go through that
arc of development according to the guys
of mr powell why are they jumping
why are they jumping this natural
progression of telephone development
because it's more profitable for the
companies
right
so if we can if we can skip a bunch of
steps
because it's more profitable for the
companies in terms of development can we
skip a bunch of steps in terms of
defending labor rights and paying decent
wages if it's more profitable and
beneficial to workers
do you think it makes more sense though
if we're trying to improve these
people's lives to focus on things this
is something that powell brought up like
property rights and economic freedoms
rule of law in some of these countries
before focusing specifically on
sweatshops
no and
the reason being take take a company
like nike nike is the largest private
employer in the country of vietnam
that's some serious power
right that
their actions there could dramatically
improve or not improve the lives of
millions of people not just their
workers but everybody that's attached to
their workers they are one of the
largest private employers in indonesia
right they have tremendous power
uh to be able to to impact the lives of
workers by you know if it's raising
wages
you know if you if you take like a
16 pair of nikes the labor costs on
that's about 250
right and that's going to sell for
100 to 170
okay
let's say you doubled it and had a
mechanism in place with that
doubled workers wages it was a clear
pass-through right back to the workers
well
if i'm gonna buy a hundred dollar pair
of sneakers
and you tell me well now it's a hundred
and two fifty oh and the ancillary
benefit of you paying that extra 250 is
you can help to lift lift tens of
thousands of people out of poverty
yeah most people are going to do that
especially if there were a marketing
campaign that eliminated what in
economics is called information
asymmetry so you know i know about this
stuff powell knows about the stuff the
workers know about the stuff but how
many consumers really know the reality
of these workers and what a difference
their extra two dollars and fifty cents
could make
right so if nike spent some money on
that along with
their commercials with
lebron and tiger and whoever else to
hock their products and said hey we also
want to make a difference man it would
be incredible but this it does not fit
within their ideology
phil knight the founder of nike the guy
that set the ethos for this company is a
psychopath
and i'm not saying that lightly
you know there's a great documentary
film that i would recommend to everybody
who sees this called the corporation
and what the filmmakers did they had
um
they had psychotherapists and psycho
psychiatrists analyze
a corporation as if it were a person
because a lot of this is built on the
premise that corporations are people
right and as legally they are under
united states law corporations are
people so they said all right if this
was a person
what kind of person would they be
and what they found in in terms of how
the corporation operates
that they're a psychopath
and that you know a guy like phil knight
he is at the head of that
and again we we need to challenge this
and there is there are not enough voices
coming out of the wilderness to to
challenge it i mean i was lucky enough
that through the work that i've done
i've been able to speak at more than 500
schools in 43 different states my short
documentary film behind the swoosh is
now used in
colleges and high schools all over the
u.s my work is it's featured in some
business ethics programs all in
textbooks and programs all around the
united states but there are a lot fewer
guys like me
than there are like mr powell
right something like mr powell is going
to defend what these companies do yeah
he gets money thrown out of these think
tanks get money of course the big
companies want their apologists out
there defending the status quo that
allows them to continue to exploit
people
and the planet um
now so here's the other you know another
part of this is when when we talk about
we said we if we accept the reality
we've got sweatshops now what do we do
right how do we improve them yeah how do
we improve them okay
nothing mr powell and his ilk are doing
is helping workers
nothing
i've been advocating for workers for the
last 24 years of my life nothing he has
ever written
nothing he has ever said has ever
changed the reality in the net positive
for workers and factories
all right i can tell i know that for
certain
the work that someone like myself my
colleagues uh who are in the us or in
europe that are working in solidarity
with brave workers and trade unionists
and trade union leaders in places like
indonesia that's what's changing things
i'll give you a couple of examples
back in 2000 unearthed this issue uh
called menstrual leave indonesian women
by law are guaranteed two paid days off
every month when they have their period
now usually women in the united states
hear this and they're like sign me up
for that policy right okay
the reason that it was put into place in
theory if we're on a production line and
i've got you know 15 people in my right
15 people my left the sneakers moving
down the line everybody does their
little part i do my part pass it on to
the next station if i've got my period
i'm going to have to get up and go to
the bathroom a number i mean be kind of
unique i have my period but if you had
your period right you're gonna have to
get up go to the bathroom a number of
times during your shift okay when you
get up from your station the sneakers
are still coming down the line they
start to pile up you're screwing up
production efficiency isn't being
maximized bad for business
so in theory better that you stay home
for these two days we'll adjust the line
while you're gone come back when you're
ready to work
in practice in order for a woman like
yourself to get her legally guaranteed
menstrually break first you'd have to
ask your line chief to get off the line
so you could go to the factory clinic
he's going to humiliate you and the
stories that i've heard from women just
who are asking horrendous right being
you know him
line chiefs letting everybody know that
you've got your period throwing pads
into your face like take care of it
eventually if you get to the factory
clinic what was happening uh you had to
pull your pants down and show blood in
your underwear to prove you were
menstruating to get your legally
guaranteed day off
gross violation of worker rights and
human rights okay
it took us about two years of advocating
on that
but it stopped
it didn't stop because of anything
that mr powell has ever written about
it's not because it's not because of
activism it's not because of shining
sunlight onto this i'm going to give you
another case with regard to wages
because he writes about you know wages
and raising wages and the problems that
it can cause
so in 2000 and
2012 2013 indonesian government raised
the minimum wage by 30
and there was a factory in sukabumi
indonesia where as a nike factory they
were refusing to pay the new minimum
wage they said they claimed we're
claiming nike was climbing financial
hardship remember this is the company
that was doing tens of billions of
dollars in profits billions in in net
pro revenues billions in net profits and
saying it's a financial hardship for us
to pay the new minimum wage
so they they try to get out of it and
the way that you get out of it is
if the union at the factory signs off
and agrees we'll accept less than the
minimum then it's done
well
kudos to the union committee they
refused they said nope this is new
minimum wage we are guaranteed a 30
increase under the law pay us a new
minimum wage
so the next way to end run that is if
the union committee doesn't agree
but you can get 90
of the rank and file workers on the
floor to sign off on the agreement
you can get out of paying the minimum
wage
i happen to be in indonesia when this
was going down one of the union reps
reached out to me
what ended up happening was
they they were going around on the
factory floor here you are you're a
young woman marginal high school
education came out of a farming
community and now you're you know in
this industrial job and just things are
moving fast and you got to produce and
everybody's yelling at you and then one
day the boss of the factory shows up
flanked on either side with two members
of the tni the indonesian military
right who are not well liked and not
well trusted because of their brutal
history that they've had in indonesia
and they're shoving a paper in front of
your face you need to sign this
what are you going to do
you're going to sign it
so luckily one of the union organized
one of the union committee members
clandestinely filmed this on their phone
reached out to me it went out i looked
at the footage
i interviewed a number of workers that
that had happened to interviewed the
union reps who had been you know bullied
and threatened
took all that information went back to
jakarta partnered up with a couple ngos
that are indonesian-based that i worked
with there held a massive press
conference all the international media
came we hammered them in the press for
three days and within three days
those workers are being paid the new
minimum wage
and that was worth over a million
dollars in wages to those 7 000 workers
in the first year which makes a huge
difference in their lives and you know
what
that factory's still around
and they're still producing for nike and
converse which is also owned by nike and
there's those those those sneakers are
coming out same quality somehow they
figured it out when they were publicly
embarrassed
and their brand got hit right and that's
been the most effective weapon that
we've had in doing this is to hit the
brand
is it possible that you guys
both have aspects that are right that
nike is this gargantuan company that's
you know taken over wages for certain
countries and then can force
cheap labor and that that's evil but
that some companies that have sweat
shops can end up improving the economy
in third world countries
again it comes back to a more deeper
philosophical fundamental question is
this the best way
to develop an economy that needs
developing it's unsustainable right and
it's crazy like the way the rules are
written
um
so if you and i if we went to one of the
malls in jakarta that are geared towards
expats towards westerners
there are nike shops in those malls
you know normal nike store you go in
there's all kinds of sneakers on the
wall we start pulling those sneakers off
now
if you're in the mall in say north
jakarta we could go in a number of
directions and within an hour hit a
dozen nike factories that are producing
those sneakers
right
if we flip the labels up on the tongues
of the shoes do you know where those
sneakers are made
vietnam and china
because by the rules of the world trade
organization and this is a book i'm
going to encourage all of your folks
watching this to read who's trade
organization
right this is by wallock and woodall
from public citizen
these are the rules of the global
economy and when you read it you're like
this is nuts
but isn't that crazy that they're yeah
how the sneakers are produced in
indonesia why because they give them
these tax breaks and create what are
called these epcs these export
processing zones everything has to be
made for export
that's a really crazy way to structure
your economy
but it's to the benefit of the
transnational corporations and their
shareholders
and we're starting to see some of the
the
unsustainability of this model right i'm
sure you're watching the news and like
there are different products that are
hard to get now and you got shipping
containers that are just piling up in
different places and ships can't even
get into port everybody's worried you
know about the consumerism of christmas
is the beast going to be fed
yeah because this whole model is
unsustainable and it's also
unsustainable from an environmental
standpoint
the amount of energy that has to be
consumed to move a product from
tangerine indonesia to port elizabeth
you know 45 minutes north of me
you know there are all these costs
you're external that's what economists
call externalized costs
well somebody's paying for it but we're
paying for it in terms of
climate change because the amount of oil
and gas
that has to get gobbled up to move these
products
and why is this system set up in the way
that it's set up yeah it's not it's not
to help the poor
it's not to develop local regional
national or global economy
it is to maximize profits
period
and we've been sold the the the
collective the body politic i would say
in the united states and around the
world has been sold on this this model
you know what's called the washington
consensus down in dc
uh that this is the only way to do it
and i can tell you this if we remain on
this path believing this is the only way
to do it not only will sweatshop workers
continue to get exploited
but
we will accelerate what is already
happening with regard to the climate
crisis and
you will also start to see economies
fractured
because if you think of it like a piece
of gum
and you start pulling it apart and here
on this one end is this giant blob where
all the benefits profits are aggregating
and over here it just keeps getting
thinner and thinner
eventually what's going to happen it
snaps
and what is that snapping going to look
like
political instability we're seeing that
all over the world
right food insecurity starting to see
that all over the world
shortages in potable water
right i mean you could go through a
whole laundry list to me this the issue
of sweatshops you know there was when
when students started to take this issue
on right about the same time when i was
doing my graduate work
in a big way you know they would say
that um you know
sweatshops is like a gateway drug
in terms of opening up your mind and
starting to question how this whole
system is
structured uh you know what one thing is
i read as i was reading through mr
powell's work he reminded me of a
colleague of mine a guy's name is david
corton this is the second book i'm only
going to give two to people watching
this i could give you a whole library's
worth of two
when corporations rule the world
okay it's an international bestseller by
david corton corton is no pie in the sky
lefty
right corton uh did his mba at stanford
he was the guy that was in the class
with phil knight that i mentioned
earlier when phil knight presented how
he was going to exploit cheap labor
he finishes nba he continues on in the
stanford business school to get his phd
in organizational theory and he believed
that guys like phil knight like that was
the way to help these poor countries
that you know you lower the barriers to
trade you pump in the foreign direct
investment these people are going to get
jobs in the real economy whatever that
means you know the rising tide is going
to lift all ships and everybody's going
to do great we're all going to hold
hands at the end and sing kumbaya right
well courtney went out in the field for
30 years working for usaid working for
corporations working for the ford
foundation
setting the framework and you know he
worked in indonesia he would be the one
talking to the government saying here's
what you got to do to allow a company
like nike to come in and here's how it
should be set up and this is what it
should look like
30 years of his life work pushing that
washington consensus pushing the
neo-liberal development model pushing
the arguments that mr powell and and his
colleagues these libertarian market
fundamentalists make and i give david
all the credit in the world imagine 30
years of your life work
and taking a step back
and then saying courageously to yourself
first and then to the world
i've done nothing
to help these poor people
all i have done is help corporations get
rich
and it for his title to help
corporations rule the world
and
to me this should be mandatory reading
for every student in in business school
or even if you're not in business school
because it really gives the framework of
how because he goes historically how we
got here how we got to this point where
a company like nike can do
what it's continued to do
it tears apart the arguments that a guy
like you know mr powell would make
um and david would be you know because
when i read through papers like this
i understand it
i i understand the economic jargon
that's utilized we so over complicate
this stuff
right and part of it is so that you know
it's almost like with lawyers as well we
we create like this legal language so
well then what do you got to do you got
to pay a lawyer 250 an hour to interpret
the language
when we can really explain this stuff in
very simple common sense ways
and i think at the end of the day
specific to this issue
one we can have production plants that
are making shoes and clothes
they don't have to be sweatshops
well how would they not be sweatshops
you'd pay people a decent wage and
they'd have a union contract in place or
they would collectively own the factory
you'd have a worker-owned cooperative
right so it's not like i'm saying hey
we shouldn't have any factories although
i do think we need to question
whether or not
um you know
people need seven pairs of nikes
right with our sneaker heads that are
out there we do have a consumption
question that we have to address
i also think we we can say hey we need
factories but do those factories need to
be producing for export like the current
model under the rules of the world trade
organization in these export processing
zones
well there are 220 million probably more
than that now maybe 250 million
indonesians
all of them need good shoes
why not have factories in indonesia
produced for indonesians
but for for that i guess my question
would be
do indonesians have that much money to
buy shoes compared to where they're
exporting to well they're not going to
be so yeah so here's the thing the your
average pair of nike sneakers that if
you went to dick's sporting goods like
pick a store right
and i'm not talking about the high end
lebrons or yeah you know the jordans
that you're going to get a carrying case
and promotional stuff with it is that
run-of-the-mill cross trainer at 75
bucks
those shoes cost about
six to eight dollars to make
so
if you sold them right out of the
factory
at
let's say let's say it's a six dollar
pair of shoes
and the factory right now when they're
selling to nike is making about a dollar
a pair
all right sell right to the indonesian
consumer
and make your dollar appear
and then that money is actually going to
stay within the local economy
and it uh it's going to increase what
economists call the velocity of money
you're going to see that dollar change
over at the local level it's going to
have way more of an impact if we truly
want to develop these countries in these
economies
okay that
that makes sense but then i guess with
these and i know we're running out of
time but would these companies have
money to set up production in the first
place without having nike behind them
sure look you're if if there's money to
be made you're always going to have
people that are going to look to invest
right it's a question of what we're
investing in what are the rules
how how do we set this up governments
can play a much stronger role in
you know the unfortunate reality is
especially here in the united states you
know our government because of the
citizens united uh supreme court
decision that allowed the floodgates to
open for big money into politics whether
you're on the right or the left
republican democrat like they're all
bought for not
the majority of them are bought
by the big moneyed interests
right so you know you get laws
that are passed uh regulations that are
created that are to the benefit of these
corporations why because they're helping
to put those people in office and keep
them in office
right so we really need a much broader
and deeper systemic analysis of of
what's going on here and i i think that
what's great about this sweatshop issue
like i said it's it's that gateway
and and as as far as an issue goes
it's literally touching us
right like we're wearing this issue
right now so it's very tangible it's
very real i think it's easy for people
to start to wrap their heads around
but then it does you know as you
continue down this path
it demands a much broader and deeper
systemic analysis
of you know how our global economy is
structured uh how that filters down from
the um
the global level to the national level
the interplay of government and commerce
uh how consumers and other stakeholders
fit in like there's a lot to to unpack
but i think at a very a very basic level
what's happening right now in these
production plants is unfair and unjust
you know these
these are
uh the people who are generating the
real wealth
when i say real wealth i mean stuff you
can actually touch stuff you know the
shoes you put on your feet the shirt you
pull over your head
and they're not
benefiting nearly enough from generating
that wealth
i i don't think you should have somebody
like phil knight who aggregates in the
billions in wealth where those billions
are built on the backs on the blood
sweat and tears of mostly young women
who are producing the real wealth in
these production plants around the world
okay
thank you very much for coming on if if
people want to find you where should
they go sure uh you can find me on
social media on twitter at
uh jw keaney j-w-k-e-a-d-y
on instagram jw keati uh and on facebook
jimpidi ke ady and i i do hope to hear
from people if people have additional
questions
concerns want more book recommendations
or documentary film recommendations
certainly the educator in me would would
want to provide those
or if you wanted me you know if you're a
student or professor and you want me to
come to your campus or zoom in on your
campus we'd love to do that as well
okay thanks very much for coming on all
right thanks for having me have a great
day
you too
if mr if mr powell believes in his
arguments and that hey this is just
these this is the best we can do okay
then trade places trade places for six
months
go work in a production plan go live on
pennies an hour
and i want to see if you're going to
still make the same arguments when you
get back from that experience
and then you ask well what why shouldn't
you know
or
he might say well
hey it's i'm here there okay so again
switch places and what makes you better
why do you deserve mr powell i'm gonna
guess and i could be wrong and i'm open
to him challenging me why do you deserve
a six-figure salary
a nice home a nice car retirement
savings
not being beaten at work not being
sexually harassed not go through the
whole laundry list of issues that
factory workers deal with why do you
deserve what you've got and they don't
because by raw you were born 13 000
miles away in a country that went
through that awful period and you're
standing on the the shoulders of that
now other people had to suffer and die
right so now oh it's their turn over
there now let it be your turn and if
you're not willing to let it be your
turn then you know at a guttural level
fundamentally
that there's a problem with this system
there's a problem with your arguments if
you're not willing to trade places
right and i've laid this challenge out
to athletes to
elected officials to phil knight the
chairman of the board at nike and i'll
lay it out to power let's go to
indonesia i'll go back
i'll go back for a month i'll do the
same experiment all over again and you
and i will sleep on the cement floor
together we'll fend off the rats and the
cockroaches at night you'll feel the
pangs of hunger as you're trying to
survive on a nike sweatshop wage and
i'll guarantee you you'll chicken out
like every other person that i put this
challenge to you won't do it because not
only will it test you as an individual
it's going to test all of the nonsense
that you write in your economic
theorizing because it's going to get
real then it's gonna get real for you
and these aren't gonna just be things
that you're writing about for some trade
publication
now it's going to to hit you on the
human level
and my hope would be
that once you've had that experience
you know there's uh father colvin back
who was the superior general of the
jesuits a number of years back jesuits
catholic order of priests he said in a
famous speech when the mind is touched
by direct experience the heart may
be challenged to change
right may
so i want to offer that to mr powell
right we're not going to go like as a
and i'm i'm looking i i'm trying to find
i've researched i've read his stuff i've
looked at other things i really don't
see anywhere where he has spent a fair
amount of time sitting with workers
in their reality
listening to them
not cherry picking to try and find
things that are going to defend what
he's talking about but really getting to
know people in a human way
if it was his
a relative of his a daughter a sister
who had to prove she was menstruating
right who was illegally fired what do
you say well hey
this is the case for sweatshops
you just got to deal with it suck it up
this is part of development or would he
be fighting with righteous anger
to try to transform that situation in
that system
i'd like to believe the latter but i
don't know because he's not in that spot
so if he wants to put himself in that
spot
the invitation stands
and on that note i do have to run
okay thank you very much for coming on
yeah take care bye-bye bye jim keaney
gets all emotional and does
grandstanding challenge
he misconstrues the nature of the
argument that i've made what he doesn't
seem to get is that i fundamentally
agree with him that the goal is to
improve the lives of the workers so it's
not a matter of gaining empathy for them
or understanding their condition better
i understand their conditions stink
and i understand that we want them to
get better the question is what actually
delivers on making their lives better
i've argued in my published works and in
short in this video about why mandating
higher wages makes their lives worse why
mandating better working conditions
actually makes their lives worse jim
does nothing to actually engage the
intellectual argument and explain why
those policies would not have the
effects that i do i do talk about things
that would make their lives better
giving them more migration visas to a
richer country how the process of
development has lifted people out of
poverty in the past how paying kids to
go to school instead of working
factories can help lower child labor
those are positive things that can be
done
what jim lives in is a world where he
doesn't have an intellectual argument of
why his favored policies would actually
help the workers so instead he spends
his time making grand gestures and
appealing to people's emotions
thinking with your brain
not feeling with your heart is the way
to help these workers and if jim really
wants to do challenges i suggest that he
take up the challenge of learning
economics so he can understand price
theory because without understanding
that he ends up for advocating for
things that actually hurt the workers he
purports to say that he wants to help
they deserve better
[Music]
you